hey dr. Berg here in this short video
we're going to talk about the water a
myth I know you were taught that you
need to drink eight glasses of water a
day
I was taught that everyone knows that
that's what they say you need to do well someday I'm gonna find who they is
because every time I find out a concept
that everyone is doing because we just
have to do it
I'm suspect because it turns out most of
those recommendations end up to be false
down the road so I guess the common
thought is you have to drink half of
your body weight in ounces so if I'm 200
pounds that's a hundred ounces that's
twelve and a half glasses of water a day
that's a lot of water and that's eight
ounce glasses okay so let's just go
through this okay number one sixty
percent of the body is water is that
true no it's not true
in fact zero percent of your body is
water not one millimetre of your body is
pure water it's all electrolyte fluids
you got your blood
you live your urine all these fluids are
electrolytes that's minerals it's sodium
potassium calcium and a lot of other
stuff in these fluids it's not just pure
water so that's kind of a a falsity
number two the body doesn't know when
it's thirsty I love this well first of
all it does know when is thirsty you can
perceive thirst hunger hot cold
temperature you can perceive a lot of
things you have 52 perceptions of
perceiving a lot of stuff so when
someone tells you well sometimes when
you're hungry you're really thirsty
they're just making stuff up okay all
right that's a false all right so now
number three water flushes out the fat
so you need to drink more water because
it helps you with losing weight there's
never been one person that lost even an
ounce of fat by drinking more water it's
a myth you can't lose weight by drinking
more water because fat is fat soluble
it's not water soluble it doesn't
dissolve by pouring more water on to it
it's not going to happen
try this take a slab of bacon fatty
bacon and pour water and shake it up and
see if it dissolves I tell you the stuff
that people believe it's incredible or
they say drink more water because you're
going to eat more eat less calories
right because it's you're going to not
be as hungry
well yeah until you have to use the
bathroom all right number four water
flushes out toxins
well again toxins are fats Seibel
they're not water-soluble and that would
be like pesticides insecticides
herbicides drugs they're all fat soluble
they're not water soluble so it's not
going to flush anything out it's going
to get stuck in the fat so drinking more
water is not going to flush those out
okay number five water helps dry skin
not true dry skin is a deficiency of
vitamin A and that's in the skin that is
in the eyes it's in the dry mouth your
body will dry out when it doesn't have
the oils in the fat not the water same
thing with your joints your joints are
lubricated and your your skin is
lubricated and it will look young when
you have oil and fat but it's not water
the people that drink the most water
actually are the most dehydrated now how
can that be because the the difference
in electrolytes there's a condition
called hyponatremia and that is a
condition where you can die of and it's
drinking too much water because it's
going to flush out all the electrolytes
and the cells are going to swell because
they have no electrolytes to mobilise
the fluid even your brain will swell you
can even have a coma a heart attack
enlarged liver okay seizures so all
these things can come by drinking so
much water alright so I probably drink
on a given day maybe two maybe three
cups of water a day that's what I drink
your body adjust if you drink less
you'll pee less if you drink more you'll
pee more your body is always trying to
maintain natural balance
I personally drink Pellegrino because I
like the carbonation some people don't I
like this it's mineral water naturally
from the I think it's Italy and this is
what I drink but you could just drink
filtered water but here's the thing make
sure you only drink when you're thirsty
and if you have someone pushing this
water on you just go ahead and send this
video I'll see you in the next video